this morning the airforce will launch
the first of a powerful new generation
of GPS satellites the satellite is
nicknamed Vespucci after America's
namesake Explorer Amerigo Vespucci it
will blast off from Cape Canaveral
Florida aboard a SpaceX Falcon 9 rocket
now this is the first national security
launch for SpaceX mark Strassmann shows
us how the military mission benefits
billions of people on earth everyone
from pilots to first responders to
everyday drivers in the road an
estimated 4 billion people worldwide
rely on GPS now the US Air Force's
system of GPS satellites is about to get
a long-overdue makeover beginning with a
launch of this 577 million dollar
satellite GPS is really a military
system but it has provided incredible
capability for the everyday user the
satellite built by Lockheed Martin is
the first of 32 planned GPS 3 satellites
that will replace older ones in orbit
among its upgrades a stronger military
signal that's harder to jam and location
information that's three times more
accurate new satellites also have
civilian channels that will improve
everything from your ability to drive
your car around town to search and
rescue operations and the list goes on
and on still the launch comes four years
behind schedule and many of its key
features won't be fully up and running
for at least a few more years the
overarching reason they're running
behind schedule is the command and
control segment building the software
and the infrastructure on the ground
that can they can talk to these
satellites and do it all at a level of
encryption it's simply unprecedented
Lockheed Martin says today's liftoff
marks the first of what it hopes is a
steady flow of satellite launches with a
public feeling the impact of the new and
improved system by the end of 2020 for
CBS this morning
I'm mark Strassmann
look I'm all for that improvement
certainly using our ways and other
abilities GPS it helps me I use it every
day change our lives by 2020 we will
know where we're going down we have to
wait that long
enjoy the journey teehee